well I think the best hope for finding
some kind of objective moral philosophy
is to think about how and why these
Progressive changes happen and to think
about the psychological and cultural
mechanisms behind them and whether those
mechanisms can be exploited in the
future we're not going to figure out
whether utilitarianism is true or not
but we might be able to figure out how
we've made progress in ways that we all
agree in our progress and how to build
on those and to find agreement about
other pressing problems that we haven't
solved yet
why would evolutionary theory at all be
involved in a conversation when studying
morality
it's a pleasure to be on the show uh the
reason is because we are our evolved
beings we are uh we didn't create
morality from scratch we inherited from
our ancestors we have similar capacities
for Morality that are shared with other
animals like chimpanzees and so the
first step to understanding morality is
to understand where it came from
okay
does morality not just come out of
culture is this not just something that
humans create out of the wishy-washy
nowhere of interacting with each other
I mean it comes out of culture too
because culture evolved uh so
culture evolves just like our genes do
we have information we pass it on
information that allows us to
succeed in our environment is more
likely to be transmitted to the Next
Generation so when we think of morality
as being evolved it's not just genetic
capacities to feel pro-social emotions
and care about other creatures it's also
a culturally evolved system of norms and
institutions and all of these things
combine to produce human morality so you
call that Gene culture co-evolution
that's right yeah there's been a huge
literature over the past couple of
decades trying to explain how it's not
just that genes evolve and cultural but
they co-evolve together they influence
each other's evolution okay so could you
give me an example of how
culture has influenced genes
yeah that's a great question so one of
my favorite examples of this has to do
with the gene that creates alcohol
aversion so there are some populations
in different parts of the world that uh
are averse to alcohol that is when they
drink it their face blushes they get
kind of sick asian flush asian flush my
business partner my business
that's right and the reason for that is
that the those populations in Asia were
among the first people to take
domesticated rice crops and turn them
into alcohol and so there was
um this evolved cultural practice of
domesticating rice turning it into
alcohol and that created a selection
pressure on our genes that is
individuals who were averse to alcohol
were less likely to become alcoholics
and get drunk and ruin their own lives
and those are their family and so they
were more likely to pass along their
genes to the Next Generation no way
that's where Asian flesh comes from
that's right yeah that is incredible so
because the sort of person who would be
either neutrally or positively
predisposed to consuming alcohol
would be more likely to be in situations
that would stop their survival and
reproduction
people for whom their bodies ended up
having this response where they got hot
and red-faced and they felt sick were
less likely to do that they're less
likely to take the risks and make the
errors which means that they're more
likely to pass their genes on so asian
flush is an Adaptive response to
encourage people genetically to not
drink in order to not do stupid [ __ ]
while they're drunk
that's right yeah if you blowing my mind
that's so interesting
yeah there's tons of exam tons of
examples like this okay keep them coming
I want to know some more give me some of
this sure yeah so another famous one has
to do
um with
um lactase tolerance so uh sorry lactose
tolerance so you know most mammals lose
the genes from producing the enzyme
lactase that allows us to digest lactose
in milk humans are one of the only
Exceptions there are some populations
across the world that keep this enzyme
and that allows us to continue drinking
milk in dairy product eating dairy
products through adulthood and uh the
reason for this is and this is just uh
you know it seems like the best
hypothesis because of where those genes
are located in the world is that those
are the places where uh human beings had
domesticated cows or goats and
um so there was a selective advantage in
being able to continue to to consume
Dairy
um without getting sick and you know
there's been some new research on this
that adds a little twist but basically
the only twist is that um these this
really happened in places that were
prone to starvation
and so the key thing was to be able to
drink Dairy without experiencing
diarrhea diarrhea and becoming
um uh dehydrated so that's that's
another example though of a culturally
evolved practice which is Raising goats
and cows for milk influences the
evolution of our genes to produce this
enzyme that allows us to eat milk drink
milk eat milk drink milk and eat dairy
products without experiencing
dehydration
does this suggest that all humans went
through a stage of lactose intolerance
and then there was a re-mutation which
was adaptive and the people that were
descended from that particular cohort
became better or does it seem like the
uh the sort of loss of the lactase
occurred all at the same time and then
it was stopped within certain cohorts
does that make sense
I think the idea is that it was uh the
original Universal trait is that this
enzyme disappeared in after childhood
and then just in a few populations
they're about this ability to retain the
enzyme
in adulthood does mother's milk is that
when you say after childhood is that
because you need to be able to have his
mother's milk like it's not dairy but
how does that work
yeah I mean it is a form of dairy uh
that has lactose in it and so that's why
we have this Gene in childhood so that
we can drink mother's milk okay very
interesting so what we're going to use
the word morality a lot what are you
defining as morality
yeah so I mean ultimately the idea is to
understand Morality In the same way that
we understand our uh agricultural
practices as this co-evolution between
culture and genes but what is it that
we're trying to explain
um I think there's lots of different
things that fall under the category of
morality but some of the main things we
want to explain is our emotions the
feelings that we have towards mother one
another like sympathy caring about other
people suffering in and of itself that's
one aspect of morality another aspect of
morality and this is something that we
don't seem to share with other animals
is humans have social norms they have
rules that prescribe how we should and
shouldn't behave and that we enforce on
other people as well so these are two of
the key key elements of human morality
emotions and norms and we want to
understand how these things evolve
through biological and cultural
evolution
all of the examples that you've given
there are
social in one form or another they
involve multiple people is there such a
thing as individual morality in your
view
uh I think that people do develop moral
codes that apply to themselves you know
people think that I have an obligation
to keep myself healthy and that has
nothing to do with other people but I
don't think that that is uh an
evolutionarily ancient tendency the uh
the tendency to apply morality yourself
the thing that's evolved is the social
the social aspect of our thinking and
our Behavior and the more individual
stuff that just comes later that's sort
of a byproduct of evolve social morality
okay so most traits that have stuck
about except for some strange byproducts
are here because they're adaptive right
they help us to survive and or reproduce
in what ways is morality adaptive
yeah well some morality is adaptive in
that it enables cooperation you know one
of the things that we have in common
with other animals like chimpanzees is
that we live in social groups that in
which we rely on another one another to
survive but the thing about humans is
that we have lived in richer Cooperative
groups than other animals so we
cooperate in a wider range of ways we
cooperate when it comes to child care
in ways that other animals don't we
cooperate when it comes to fighting
other groups in ways that animals doubt
our Cooperative schemes are much richer
and so we need a richer Morality In
order to cooperate with one another
so in this way is morality uh just a set
of inbuilt guidelines and rules that
create effective more effective
cooperation under incredibly complex and
criss-crossing situations
that's right I mean that's part of it
part of it is that it's these inbuilt
Tendencies but remember because
morality is the product of Gene culture
coevolution it's also this culturally
transmitted set of rules and practices
and institutions that in each generation
combined with our inborn inheritance to
produce that morality that different
societies construct presumably this must
mean that over time uh progressions in
culture unlock particular genetic
progressions and progressions
genetically unlock particular cultural
progressions
that is definitely the TR the case when
it comes to the Long View of human
evolution over the course of tens or
hundreds of thousands of years
it's a much more difficult question to
know whether that is continuing to
happen whether different groups across
the world are changing the Morality In
terms of their genetic inheritance in
response to different cultural
conditions you know it's very hard to
study it's easier to study Evolution
over the long scale it's much harder to
know how humans are evolving now or in
the last few decades or centuries you
say that received wisdom has it that
just because a trait is biological does
not mean that it is inevitable but
another piece of wisdom not yet widely
received is that just because a trait is
cultural does not mean that it is
optional what does that mean
yeah so I think that um a lot of people
think that
um if something's merely cultural
if it's not part of our genes it's not
part of our built-in biology then it's
something we can change but that's not
necessarily true I mean there's many
aspects of our culture that we need for
development to unfold in any kind of
normal predictable way I mean think
about for example one aspect of culture
that we take for granted which is
um
Care by child uh by caregivers in very
early
childhood I mean often historically has
come from mothers but of course can come
from other parents as well
um this is something that is cultural at
least in part
but uh it's not optional that is human
beings cannot develop in a normal
functional way unless they have this
important cultural input in their
childhood
interesting so
it's that's that's an interesting
example because it's not optional for
the child but it is optional for the
parent
it's yeah optional for the parents but
not optional for
um the gene the child and for and and
well and for the and for future
generations to continue to exist and to
flourish yes if you're a if you're a
grandparent optimizing machine it's no
longer optional yeah that was that's
more about the reproduction rather than
the survivability part is there any are
there any other examples of this about
the sort of the optionality or lack
thereof of cultural stuff
yeah I mean so one of the lessons that
has come out of work in cultural
Evolution over the last
decade or two is really the important
way in which human beings are social
Learners we don't come up with our ideas
from scratch we don't uh mainly
experiment with the world on our own we
learn ideas from other people we learn
ideas especially from peers who are a
little bit wiser than us and so uh
learning from peers is having peers that
are social models that you can learn
from is a part of culture that's
necessary for humans to develop properly
to raise the Next Generation
Um but it's not optional we need social
learning from peers in order to succeed
in our environments without social
learning from peers you would be at a
severe disadvantage when it came to
survival
that's right yeah right okay yeah that
is interesting it is very strange to
consider that there are elements of
culture that are non-optional as a part
of proceeding forward okay so what does
the human's moral mind consist of
yeah so they're you know human Minds
moral minds are incredibly diverse
across societies but
um I think there are some features that
each human being has in common at least
as long as they've had proper caregiving
in their early childhood
um so one aspect is we have a rich set
of moral emotions that we feel toward
other people especially within our
family and our social groups so these
are emotions like sympathy but also
Trust
respect
this is respect is a good one because
it's something that other
um
other primates don't have you know in
chimpanzee groups respect only Flows In
One Direction it flows up to the
dominant male in your group but humans
have mutual respect we
um we uh we don't try to adopt I mean we
we don't always try to dominate it we
have an Impulse to
um have relatively
egalitarian groups where we can can we
we stand on the same
um same level as other people in our
group so this is one aspect of of
evolved morality another aspect is moral
norms
so Norms like not hurting other people
helping people when they are in need of
help
um Norms about
um respecting other people's autonomy
um there's quite a wide set of norms but
they all human societies all tend to
have some similar types of norms in
common so we have norms for example
about not causing harm to other people
we have Norms that are about respecting
other people's autonomy Norms that have
to do with fairness
and these are interpreted in wildly
different ways across Societies in some
places fairness is about equal
distribution of resources in other
places it's about giving people what
they're owed depending on how much
effort they put in or what their social
status is
um so these are two aspects of human
morality and the third one and this is
one that I think psychologists don't pay
enough attention to is the human
capacity for moral reasoning
this is another thing that sets us apart
from the Apes we
um have the ability to change what our
moral views are and we don't do it in
the way that philosophers generally
reason about morality we don't start off
with first principles and apply them to
specific cases a more typical way that
humans reason about morality is we do
something called moral consistency
reasoning or treating like cases alike
you know somebody in your group somebody
that you trust might say well listen
why are you treating him that way you
wouldn't want to be treated that way
yourself or to think of a more modern
example many people come to be
vegetarians or vegans or reduce their
meat consumption because they think
somebody in their social group pointed
out like hey you you really care about
dogs you wouldn't want dogs to be
tortured in that way
why why do you think it's okay to
torture pigs or cows in that way
so moral emotions moral norms and a
capacity for moral reasoning these are
the main ingredients of evolved
biocultural morality are there any
emotions that aren't moral
oh yeah plenty of promotions so uh fear
is not
uh doesn't need to be in a moral emotion
I mean sometimes you can feel fear
towards other people that are uh trying
to exert their moral power over you but
many times you feel fear towards and you
know uh non-human objects or in
situations that don't have anything to
do with morality yeah that's interesting
so what other
primary moral emotions are there other
the most moral emotions that we've got
are there a little bundle of them
yeah so it's this is like
uh no it's an open question
Falls in here but I think some of the
main contenders are sympathy
um
uh reciprocity
or rather the trust the emotion of trust
that underlies reciprocity
respect that we've already talked about
and there's another one that doesn't get
much play in Western ethics and Western
thinking too which is
um
uh is connected with loyalty but it's
like the emotional bonding that forms
between people not just because we're
part of the same group but because we're
bonded as mates or as close friends or
Coalition partners
when it comes to respect you said that
typically uh in terms of primates
respect flows one way which is from the
subordinates to the person that's in
charge the chief ape what chimp or
whatever
yeah
what is the difference between humans
and chimps that makes us require mutual
respect as opposed to one-way respect
yeah I think it again has to do with the
the Richer and more egalitarian forms of
cooperation that humans have relied on
for hundreds of thousands of years so
chimpanzee groups can
they don't have to they cooperate but
not very much and so they can get away
with one dominant ape hogging all the
resources if that's what they want
hogging all the mating opportunities if
that's what they want
um but the this kind of has lip this
limits cooperation in a way like for
example if you and I are in an ape group
and you're taking all the food the fruit
or the meat when we get it then I have
kind of less of an incentive to to give
it my all in the next on the next
Cooperative run
but if you know we're in circumstances
which humans found themselves in where
they really desperately needed to
cooperate in order to fend off
um their territory from attackers in
order to access new forms of food like
for example Scavenging and hunting other
animals
um then we need to operate on terms of
relative equality if we're gonna really
both of us give it our all and
um and and cooperate to do these these
harder more complicated tasks
so we had to give up dominance
relationships in order to cooperate in a
more complex complex and reliable way I
heard David putz on the show not long
ago and he was talking about how chimp
society's
uh 100 times to 500 times more violent
in terms of the number of violent
incidents than humans are but they are
100 times less lethal
so he said that interestingly one of the
one of the outcomes that you get from
that is a huge predisposition amongst
humans to avoid conflict as soon as you
move on from it being a a pushing
shoving match that's actually going to
take quite a while for you to kill
somebody else to you with a heavy rock
or a sharp stick or a spear or a gun or
a you know progress on with your
lethality of weapon of choice
you end up having an incentive to very
very much avoid uh that kind of physical
interaction and I suppose that this is
where dominance versus Prestige from a
leadership perspective comes in
why in a human society would you want a
complete Tyrant at the absolute top
unless it was somehow helping you and
that means that the only way really that
tyrants in human society can stick about
is if they have a little cohort of
sycophants or whatever around them that
can help them to kind of keep everyone
and then they need a military arm and
they need a bunch of sort of supporters
below them as well
um when it comes down to sympathy I
remember reading I think it was Jonathan
height or Robert Wright maybe who said
they put forward they thought sympathy
was investment advice they said that
sympathy suggests to humans which other
humans will be the most appreciative of
their efforts toward them so I'm gonna
guess that sympathy
helps us to redistribute resources in a
more efficient manner is that right
I think that's certainly part of it I
mean
part of this view of sympathy that you
just suggested seems to be about the
communicative function of sympathy me
expressing sympathy for you communicate
something to you about uh
who's worth you're reinvesting in
um but I also think that another aspect
of sympathy is just that
um if we are really bound up together
uh if if my interests are bound up with
yours then it behooves me to make sure
that you have enough food that you're
happy that you're not going to run off
and join another Cooperative scheme
without me so when you know the to
when
when social interaction becomes less and
less of a zero-sum game when
um your your positive outcomes are
really bound up with mine then it it
benefits me not just in a communicative
way but it benefits me to act in ways
that serve your interest because your
your interests will serving your
interests will will benefit mine okay
what I've got in my head here is the
fact that in a small scale Society
sympathy makes an awful lot of choice
if you were to start to scale that up a
little bit more where you are less
reliant on the others in your group less
reliant on the others in your group
surviving
that would suggest to me that sympathy
would start to get turned down does that
does that seem to make sense
absolutely and I mean the thing about
human societies for hundreds of
thousands of years is that we've lived
in very small groups where you uh you
know other people you really are
um bound up to them in in terms of all
kinds of Cooperative uh activities and
uh you know this this may be true at
least for tens of thousands of seizures
but certainly in the last few hundred
and thousand years we live in much
larger societies where
um there aren't the same Cooperative
dependencies between people who are
living in the same city or the same
um village as you and so here I think
um
there really is uh
uh there there isn't the same incentive
to feel and express sympathy towards
others and what we've seen I think in
in society societies that have persisted
is that we've seen that there have
evolved cultural institutions
that manage the work of cooperation for
us so we don't have to rely on you and I
having a personal relationship we've got
a system of laws that will punish me for
um for hurting you and you know uh
a bunch of people who will enforce it in
lessons if I was to steal your property
if you were some Down and Out person who
lived in a on benefits in some house
somewhere and then I came in and stole
your final tin of beans or whatever it
was there is the potential that you
would use laws which are like
legislative
um written down Norms that would then be
enacted by a wing that is an exterior
enforcer of those Norms the police who
would then come and say give that to the
beans back
not only is it theirs but there is then
this sort of
um cultural sense that somebody who is
down and out is deserving of uh not
being uh pushed around that's why seeing
videos of two guys fighting in the
street feels very different to seeing a
video of a guy pushing over granny
yeah yeah and I think that's right I
think that's the way in which some of
the functions of human morality have in
recent centuries in Lydia been
outsourced to political legislative
enforcement apparatuses
what about
other less moral but still slightly
moral emotions
hmm
like did you have any in mind well I I'm
not sure I'm thinking about that you've
got those four across the top but
there's a whole list of emotions that
humans that humans do have I'm wondering
whether there are secondary if there's a
secondary set of them as well
yeah so there are another set of
emotions that are not really
um specific to
um that that that motivate a specific
kind of behavior like helping people or
not taking advantage of them there's
another second order set of emotions
that are things like guilt on the one
hand or shame and resentment or moral
anger so these are emotions that kind of
um keep you in check by getting people
by motivating people to follow the moral
rules that are around because you'll
impose some emotional cost on yourself
you'll feel guilt or shame if you
violate the rules or other people will
experience anger and retaliate against
against you if you if you violate the
rules so I think of these emotions like
shame and resentment these are these are
fully fully immoral emotions they're
just a little bit different than the
ones we've been talking about already
yeah that's that adds in another
area here that I think I was missing
shame being uh self-flagellation about
transgressing a moral Norm that maybe
even nobody else knew about uh perhaps
even something that didn't affect
anybody else a promise that you made to
yourself about the kind of person that
you would be I am going to get up at
seven o'clock in the morning tomorrow
morning and I woke up at nine o'clock
and I feel like a piece of [ __ ] or guilt
around
um eating a cookie or about stealing
that tin of beans from Granny it's a uh
an internal police system
that helps that doesn't require the law
and the legislation and the police to
come around you do it to yourself
that's right and I think that's because
even in modern societies we we need both
internal morality and the morality
that's externalized onto our
institutions because of course we still
have these close personal relationships
with people around us who depend on us
and that's the kind of thing that Shane
regulates and when it comes to things
about which we're Shameless that's when
we need the external institutions in
your opinion is it right to say that
there are good or bad emotions
I think that emotions can be used in
good in bad ways I think that uh it's
there are philosophers who argue that
some emotions are inherently bad like
anger or disgust disgust maybe one of
those that you had in mind that is kind
of halfway moral
um but I think all of these emotions
have their place I mean anger of course
can lead to violence it can uh be
self-stultifying because
um expressing anger may lead other
people to distrust you or avoid you but
anger is also important as a motivator I
mean it can motivate people to fight
against Injustice it can motivate people
to hold
people responsible in their
interpersonal relationships if you don't
feel anger at your wife or your husband
um unless they're a perfect moral being
you're probably not going to have a
functioning relationship where you are
holding each other responsible and
um and and and you know developing and
developing a relationship in positive
ways moral disgust is an interesting one
because drawn into that is uh all manner
of bigotry and and Prejudice and
predisposition and stuff like that what
what role does moral discuss have I
understand the reason why looking at
rotting meat or the smell of feces or
open wounds stuff like that I understand
why that would create a sense of disgust
first off it is the moral disgust system
I don't know whether you've ever looked
at it from like a neurobiological
neuroscientific perspective is it the
same system that's activated
yeah so this is a this is an open
question there are people in the
literature who argue on on different
sides of this issue I don't think it's
been solved yet
um there does seem to be
um
uh things in common between basic
pathogen disgust and moral disgust so
for example there are studies suggests
that
um that similar parts of the brain have
the insular cortex are activated when
people experience disgust towards rotten
food versus
um towards people who are dishonest or
exploitative
um there's also research that should
suggests that when you
um
when you're experiencing moral disgust
people
uh people make the gate base they do the
disgusted facial expression that's
typical of pathogen discuss so that's
some evidence that suggests it's one in
the same emotion or similar variation on
the same emotional system that's
responding to pathogens and moral issues
but I think this is maybe one of the
best cases for an emotion that is a
moral emotion it's related to morality
but it's not good it's a bad emotion I
don't think that's right because I think
that disgust has its place too one of
the things that people feel moral
disgust towards is is a class of
violations that have to do with
reciprocity so things like cheating
dishonesty exploitation people
experience moral disgust towards those
things and one reason disgust is useful
as an emotion is because of what it
motivates it motivates us to withdraw
and avoid and engage in distancing and
that can be a really effective form of
punishment
that is in a Cooperative species like
ourselves when people are avoiding you
or withdrawing from you that is a very
powerful indirect punishment because it
deprives you of social connections so I
think that even moral disgust has its
place too
I saw a study that came up recently that
looked at the greatest status affecting
criteria for attractiveness uh most
status increasing criteria and this is
on a scale of naught to eight how many
points it increases or decreases so
being a trusted group member 3.05 being
intelligent nearly three getting
accepted at a prestigious University
being an exceptional leader having a
wide range of knowledge being creative
always being honest being able to speak
well in public having a job that pays
well having a good sense of humor having
an executive position being kind being
brave in the face of danger having a
college education and being a hard
worker so that goes from like five to
two and a half and then the reverse the
most status decreasing criteria failing
to perform a group task getting
dismissed from school being lazy being
unable to control one's sexual behavior
when drunk being unreliable acting
immature or irresponsible possible being
mean or nasty to others expressed racist
remarks bringing social shame on one's
family having Bad Manners takes illegal
drugs getting a sexually transmitted
disease being stupid being unclean or
dirty and being known as a thief being
known as a thief by 20
is the biggest status decreasing
criteria and that made me think about
what you were just talking about that it
is it is inherently it is inbuilt with
the trust within the group The moral
discussed that you would have toward a
thief somebody that can't by their very
nature cannot be trusted to have the
group's interests at heart so we need to
move away from them
yeah that's fascinating I do think that
this study indicates that morality being
a a moral person continues to affect
your reproductive potential and
um I think that disgust can and underpin
this exact kind of response that people
have towards immoral people which is to
avoid them
you've mentioned that our closest
relatives in the primate world do not
have these moral emotions have you got
any idea at what point humans would have
evolved these
yeah so I do think that chimpanzees and
bonobos have some analog of moral
emotions they do have emotions like
sympathy the key one that I think
distinguishes us from bonobos is respect
mutual respect and so
um it's you know it's it's very hard the
evidence is so
um depleted and Scattered to figure out
when these things evolved I think the
best way to think about it is to piece
together different kinds of evidence
genetic archaeological evidence and to
try to figure out when forms of
cooperation evolved that would have
required more equality between primates
compared to the kinds of Cooperative
activities that chimpanzees and
presumably are common ancestors with
them engaged in
um one thing this is something that
Michael tomasello points to
um one thing that you see in the
archaeological record is that humans
around the time of when our genus
evolves two million two million years
ago this is a period of time where
humans are starting to rely
in a regular way on meat
you know initially probably Scavenging
meat maybe even just finding bones and
breaking it open and getting them narrow
from them but eventually cooperating in
a way to chase off other
um Predators bring down prey ourselves
and this was the kind of thing that we
needed to do we need to cooperate in
order to do it we needed to cooperate in
a more dependable
um fine-tuned way to carry out a hunt
and you know
the Lions can do it without human
morality but they're much fiercer
Predators than us we needed to
um use our intelligence rather than our
um our bare strength their speed we also
needed to use something you mentioned
earlier than more elaborate tools that
humans had begun to create around this
period of time so this is
this is one form of cooperation among
others that seems to have Arisen around
roughly two million years ago when our
genus hold up was evolving in Africa and
so this is likely the period of time
where a more complex and richer set of
moral emotions including mutual respect
probably involved I'm thinking about the
relationship the sort of Gene culture
co-evolution element of emotions
have you looked at any particular
cultures
or subgroups of people that have Unique
Blends of emotions where maybe one
particular group shows a particular
emotion way higher or lower than others
based on whatever pressures our
environment is happening around them
yeah one of the great studies of this
um this is
um
by uh psychology psychologist Richard
Nisbet and his co-author uh Doug Cohen
so this has to do with honor cultures
um so there's traditional honor cultures
in different parts of the world
um and these are places where people in
these cultures are more likely to feel
anger in response to perceived insults
or threats so this is a these are
distinct populations where people are
are experiencing more intense anger and
uh experience it in response to these
insults and threats at kind of a more of
a hair trigger
and the explanation and this is a a
cultural evolutionary explanation that
Nisbet and Cohen give is that these are
parts of the world that in which people
had portable property
they
um had they were for example goat
herders whose property could be easily
stolen
and they also lived in places that
didn't have that institutional
apparatuses those kinds of institutional
apparatuses that we talked about robust
legal and political institutions that
would enforce property rights and so
what you needed to be like in these in
these honor cultures is you needed to
get angry when people insulted or
threatened you because if you didn't
people would think you're weak and
they'd take your property
um so this is you know human morality is
flexible and it can can and continues to
change in different places and times but
this is one clear way in which moral
anger seems to have been
um heightened in response to the this
adaptive problem which is keeping your
property in a world where there's no
institutional support
I learned a couple of weeks ago about a
law in Texas which is where I currently
am that allows any two willing
participants to legally fight as long as
a police officer is present to act as a
referee
so this is this is completely permitted
both of them don't even need to give
verbal agreement although I think
Washington is somewhere else that this
is permitted to but you do need to have
a police officer present you need to say
this is what we're going to do and this
is completely legal I also found out
that the distance between the two
benches in the House of Lords in the UK
is one sword held out at arm's length so
if you were to hold a sword out at arm's
length and that's the distance between
the two and I'm going to get I mean the
British thing is much more vestigial I
suppose in that it's no one's taken a
sword into the House of Lords anymore
but you can still see there right it's
like here is a transgression and here is
one solution which is an outlet which
allows people to use this on a culture
and enact it in a particular way and
then another one is a protective
mechanism to ensure somebody who tries
to enact on a culture uh can't get too
carried away and chop the head off their
political opponent
yes and one of the things that nisbane
and Cohen talk about is the way in which
honor culture is typical of the American
South and has persisted there in part
because the first settlers of the
American South came from parts of the UK
that relied on um uh hurting animals and
you know same conditions property that's
portable no institutions to enforce it
um I wonder I mean I don't think that
Cohen and Nisbet talk about this but you
know you have to wonder whether this is
the ancestral condition that these are
the conditions that humans tended to
live in throughout most of human history
property was portable no robust
institutions and really the it's the the
absence of Honor cultures in various
parts of the world that is historically
unusual
um and it's much more common to have
yeah yeah so I mean that would play
kind of hard to prove I suppose but that
would play very much into the
um
Jonathan Heights uh theory around the
progress that we're seeing at the moment
you know if you were to live at any time
in history uh even going back and
everybody has this idea you know when
you've spent way too much time on your
phone one afternoon you think God I just
wish I was a I wish I was a nomadic
caveman this would be way easier I
wouldn't I wouldn't be distracted by all
this technology and I'd get enough sun
on me and all the rest of it but maybe
you would be living in a human society
where there is three times the amount of
anger that we have now because you don't
have the external institutions or
apparatus to be able to enforce Norms so
to your job somebody transgresses it's
your job
right right and of course Stephen
pinker's been another person who's
written a lot about this and about the
ways in which violence was much more a
regular part of our Lives until the last
few centuries
what's your thoughts about altruism here
you know it's commonly spoken about in
The evolutionary psychology literature
and we've mentioned sympathy we've
mentioned sort of cooperative
resources hunting so on and so forth
what have you come to believe about how
altruism came about
yeah I mean I think that we've been
talking about altruism uh these moral
emotions are forms of altruism there are
cases where people
um at least in to some degree care about
the interests of other people in and of
themselves and not just as a means to
their own happiness or their own
interests so uh you know sympathy it's
not just sympathy for you as long as you
can do something for me
it's
um you had to be able to do something
for me over the long history of time for
this sympathy to evolve but sympathy now
in human beings is caring about other
people for their own sake and we also
even you know think about the Norms too
enforcing Norms punishing people for
violating Norms that is a kind of
altruism too
because it involves making a personal
sacrifice and maybe exposing yourself to
retaliation
but you care about making sure others
are doing their part in in various kinds
of Cooperative activities what ways do
Norms differ from
emotions in that case or or even culture
yeah
um so one thing about Norms is that they
can have a really specific content they
can you know emotions are kind of Broad
in general they're like care about this
other person in some way but Norms are
much more specific they can say well
listen if uh you have
cooperated to take down this bison then
you get these parts and the other person
gets these parts that's what the rules
say
um so
you know this this kind of follows the
one of the developments we've been
talking about in the human evolution
which is cooperation becomes richer and
more complex and the more complex
cooperation becomes the the less you can
rely on
um fuzzy emotions and the more you need
concrete Norms with very specific
instructions about what you are and are
not allowed to do okay are there
categories of moral Norms have you
lumped them into particular buckets that
are commonly found
yeah so Jonathan height who you
mentioned before is somebody who has
tried to come up with a set of
categories for moral norms and
um I I offered a similar kind of
classification in my work
so we both think that harm Norms are one
category these are norms that tell us
harm Norms that not to hurt other people
or to Aid them when they're in need
um
uh fairness Norms or another category
uh we've all also talked about which is
things like equal distribution giving
people what they're owed
um reciprocity Norms are Another Kind
these are like Tit for Tat you do your
what you do for me and I do what I
promise to do to you promises kind of
fall under this category
and then another really important one is
um autonomy Norms which I think
height talks about but not not not quite
in in the way that uh not not quite
emphasizing this aspect of
um being free from interference and
domination from other people so
um these are some categories of norms
and each of them kind of fits with an
emotion
you know harm Norms fit with sympathy
it's because we feel sympathy sympathy
helps us conform to Norm's prescribing
harm
um respect is the emotion that leads us
to fulfill autonomy Norms it's because
uh we have mutual respect for each other
that we're not going to interfere in
each other's projects or try to control
what what each other do and so there are
these different categories of norms and
I think what other people haven't
noticed yet is that there's also these
these categories of emotions and it
seems like how they all arose is that
they co-evolt the emotions are part of
our genetic Heritage the Norms are part
of our cultural heritage and it's
because we've had both of them for so
long that we have this system of
emotions and Norms that fits together
what I'm fascinated about talking about
this is the
how would you say most recent prevalence
of moral grandstanding scapegoating uh
performative empathy and stuff like that
it's been enabled by the internet and
social media for people to be able to
take positions which are
um
socially praised but it has removed most
of the cost of somebody having to have a
hard signal of authenticity that they've
actually done it right that's the
performative part have you considered
how stuff like moral grandstanding and
scapegoating and performative empathy
kind of fit into this broader world view
and how all of the incentives work and
stuff like that
yeah virtual signaling is another
example in the same category that you're
talking about I think it comes down to
this difference that you pointed to
earlier which is that for most of human
history we've lived in these small
groups maybe uh you know 50 or 100
members and we really uh
had reliable information about other
people's character and what they do in
hard times and now we live in much
larger societies where you don't
you know there's not the same
opportunity to know what's really behind
other people's words and so we've had to
um people can uh engage much more in
cheap talk
and because you know we don't have the
same uh awareness and empathy intimacy
with one another so I think that uh the
the phenomenon of grandstanding and
virtue signaling
uh arises in this Society where we can't
we have uh no firmer way to track
people's reputations and their behavior
and we have to rely on what they say and
so this opens the the the door for
people to perform their moral
commitments and Garner sympathy and
Prestige and all kinds of other social
goods by um by talking a big game yeah
seeming like you do good rather than
actually doing good because at the
moment most people are assessed by their
opinions rather than their deeds you
know we don't get to see what nobody
gets to see what happens when you get
off the the conversation and this is an
incredibly Rich deep version of what
most people put out on the internet
right which is either just images or
just text and uh yet it's kind of funny
that
in a world in which you can get
obligation free status and Goodwill
the incentive is always going to be
there for people to overplay their hand
about how moral they are
yeah and I mean this is exacerbated by
the internet and social media which
um you know makes oh
turns so much of our interactions into a
communicative game
and
it's it's unclear you know what the
solution to the is this problem because
uh you know there are occasional
instances where people uh are
demonstrably engaged in Behavior that's
inconsistent with the virtues that
they've been signaling but it's so rare
it's so rare that that doesn't change
the incentive structure there's still a
massive incentive to
um to Virtue signal okay so what's
religion is religion a norm is religion
a culture or is it a there must be it's
evolved independently in tons and tons
of places all over the planet how have
you come to believe religions
development occurred
yeah and so this gets at um thinking
about
we've been talking about Gene culture
co-evolution but now the issue is more
strict cultural Evolution independent of
major changes in our genetic Heritage
um so over the last you know we've
talked about the moral mind emotions and
norms and how they fit together but this
moral mind also fits with our social
institutions that have evolved
culturally over the last uh 10 or 50 000
years so we have various kinds of social
institutions political institutions
military institutions family
institutions
and one of the most important
institutions in human history is
religious institutions
so
um religious institutions have shaped
our moral mind not just in terms of
religious ideology but religious
practices and rituals have changed and
expanded our moral Minds to Encompass
people who are from the same religious
tribe so Joe Henrik and naren Zion have
done some really important work on this
and one of the ideas that they put
forward is this idea that religions
religious institution the way that I
would put it and so this is a bit of my
spin on this is that religious
institutions
have been really important in the
cultural evolution of morality by
expanding our moral circles
you know generally
who you feel sympathy and respect to in
human history has been your your group
your band of 100 people and one thing
that religious religious institutions
did is that they allowed us to see other
people who share the same religion as
members of the same extended family
brothers and sisters and so they this
kind of cultural adaptation
interacted with our moral Minds to
expand our moral circles to Encompass
the whole religious tribe and not just
our local bands yes because we already
had the capacity for sympathy to people
uh but because we were in a Dunbar
number group of whatever 100 that was
usually what we were used to then we
said earlier on you get into a big city
where you don't rely on other people
especially in a modern agricultural
world where if you have sufficient
resources you don't actually care how
everybody else is getting on you know
even your farmer dies there's another
farmer probably not too far away that
you can go to so religion in your view
opens up the scope
of this to
re-engage with a broader group of people
yes yeah and I think it's been I think
religious institutions
predate Agriculture and have been around
for a really long time and are
responsible for the way in which humans
possibly starting 50 to 100 000 years
ago started to live in tribes that is
not just the band but a group of bands
that are linked together via ethnicity
and dialect and religion so this again
relates to an idea in Henrik which is
it's something that we maybe didn't talk
enough about which is the really way the
important way in which morality has
covaled with our knowledge and
Technology
so
roughly a hundred thousand years ago you
see this explosion in the fossil record
of tools and Technology things like
Spears and spear throwers and bow and
arrows but also things like sewing
needles and various kinds of craft work
um and what seems to have arisen uh
during this period of time is that
humans are beginning to live in
religious religiously unified tribes
groups of groups and the key thing here
this is something that Henrik talks
about is that what that what living in a
tribe does is that it
expands our Collective brain
it creates a larger number of people who
are communicating with each other or
generating ideas filtering each other's
ideas and
um
becoming more intelligent because of our
intellectual cooperation
so
um there's a religion along with other
social institutions has been really
important in human history because it's
allowed us to cooperate on a larger
scale which allows us to do things like
farming and agriculture but it also
allows us to be smarter and generate
more ideas and more technology and so
morality
institutional morality
that's expanded our circles has been
really important for the evolution of
our brains our minds and our
intelligence
I'm just thinking about the fact that
um religion as a
cultural response to the difficulty of
coordinating large groups of people
and that
150 or 200 000 years ago if you're in a
familial tribe of maybe 25 to 50 people
you probably don't need religion like
what you know you might have ideas and
stories that you tell about the sun
rising and so on and so forth but the
more
um I know like pro-social human element
of religion
I would imagine doesn't really need
to exist you you there would be no
adaptive reason to have that and
you already feel such a strong sense of
kinship especially if it is like just a
pan generational group you know you and
25 of your family
you don't need to layer any more on top
of that that's enough to say that
someone wouldn't have said you know we
are the chosen ones and we have been
placed here and blah blah blah right
some proselytizing caveman but do you
know what I mean it seems like yes yes
yeah
and there's there's a clue in the
archaeological record that I said I
think supports what you're suggesting
which is that you know up until about 50
or 100 000 years ago humans are confined
to small portions of the African
continent
and it's it's perhaps only until we can
cooperate in a larger tribe that we have
the the Manpower
to extend Out of Africa to not just make
some incursions into Eurasia but to
overpower the other human species that
live there at the time and ultimately to
rely on each other in our tribe to
colonize the entire world
this would suggest then that the bigger
that a human society gets
the more religion would be useful
yeah I mean I think that that I think
that generation generalization is likely
to have been true until some point in
human history I mean I think we can
think of counter examples like
China is a huge country and has not been
as religious as other countries in in
recent uh
the recent Century or so
um so I think that there I think that
I mean here's the thing to think that
religion was a very important
institution in organizing Society
determining
um the size of an effective Cooperative
population but in more recent times
there are other kinds of Institutions
that have been able to do the job just
as well or better and so you know you
think of
um very authoritarian kinds of political
institutions that can control people's
behavior in a way that's just as or more
effective than religious ideologies and
practices
other institutions have been rising in
relative prominence compared to religion
I think over the last few centuries
what have you come to believe about the
place that religion has then you know
the collapse of grand narratives and the
listlessness and the existential dread
of the modern world despite the fact
that we're more convenient than ever
people are feeling lost and alone and so
on and so forth
um it seems like religion independently
arose all over the world that would
suggest that it is an incredibly useful
adaptive response to the issue of Being
Human now presumably it's humans made
across humans but also will give you
some individual existential comfort
about the malaise of just being a you
know a fallen creature what what have
you what have you come to believe about
the the role and the reason that
religion uh
is here and sort of its current position
and lack thereof in the modern world and
what that means kind of for individual
um happiness and group cohesion
yeah I mean I think you're right that
historically religion has given people a
sense of belonging that sense of purpose
that is answered these deep
philosophical existential questions and
it's really interesting to know why it
has been fulfilling that purpose less
and less effectively for more and more
people over the last few centuries I
mean you know philosophers like me me
might think well the arguments against
religion are so strong things like you
know religious religious theory was
supposed to explain why we have
plants and animals and human beings on
the first place and now we have a much
better explanation in terms of darwinian
evolution
um
so maybe it's the arguments maybe it's
things like the problem of evil but
maybe it's something uh more
practical too I mean I think that people
have noticed the ways in which
some major religious domination
denominations have not really been out
for their own interests have been
exploiting and abusing members of that
religion and so it's not really the the
abstract philosophical arguments but the
like you're you're not taking care of me
and therefore I don't trust the account
you give of who I am and why I matter
um but I think there's this real
emptiness now I don't know that we found
anything that
can effectively take the place of
religion isn't it interesting that
religion and the the church churches
served a a um like a practical purpose
right like they created a foundation for
um communal belonging sense uh ritual
um connection to yourself and and not
only people around you but the world
around you so and so forth so like it
did things right it needed to create a a
story around that and what we lost
really was faith in the story not faith
in the things
it was this the story of of the the
rebirth or of the ascent to heaven on a
winged horse or of you know the path out
of Israel whatever like different
culture it was that you came from
but what was lost was something that was
like pretty undeniably good practically
because of issues that people had
narratively
yeah I mean I think you're identifying
these two important aspects of religion
one is the the belief aspect and the
stories in what the afterlife promises
and the other is not is this not belief
element of religion but a practice
element of religion it's what we do
together how we come together how we
engage in rituals that Mark important
events in our history and
um that part still matters
and you know and they can those
practices and rituals can still matter
even if
even if you don't believe in the stories
anymore
um and I'm not sure though that we've
got
other new institutions that
that engage in those kinds of rituals or
practices that really
um resonate with people no I would say
as well that
I wonder whether part of the commitment
to the practice
inevitably comes out of an element of
belief that you
um what what happened the baby in the
bathwater both go out together and that
trying to create a quote-unquote like
secular religion uh you talk about I
have a friend who's a cultural Christian
um so he likes to go to to church on
Sunday and do the sacrament and sing the
songs and but he doesn't believe
um and he is an incredible outlier I
have one friend that's like that as far
as I can tell uh and whether it's
CrossFit or yoga or psychedelics or you
know whatever your new practice of
choice
every single time there is usually some
sort of story that gets put on top and
the stronger the story or the more
narrative based it is the stronger the
belief you know some people really love
CrossFit but they don't love CrossFit as
much as they love yoga and some people
that really love yoga really love it but
they don't love it as much as people
that like psychedelics like psychedelics
you know because there is more story
there is more drama and narrative around
it that seems to support the practice I
don't know maybe that's just Bro Science
but it seems right to me
no I think that's right I mean I was
drawing the distinction between the
belief and practice elements of religion
and I think you're right that these two
things go together that the beliefs can
can
um really attach you to the practices
and imbibe them with more meaning and
significance I mean I think so much of
so much of modern culture is
practiceless you know it is belief and
exchange of information and ideas and
communication on the internet but it it
doesn't it there isn't any practice or
ritual that it goes along with
um and there's certainly none that seems
to unify people I mean you mentioned a
few different things here like yoga and
Crossfit and psychedelics and we can
find others but these these things are
so fragmented you know it's very small
disparate communities that are engaging
in each of these things and nothing that
really binds large members of our
culture our country together
in your opinion is it possible to have
an objective moral code what you've
suggested here is that morality kind of
is this emergent adaptive solution that
humans have to the problem of
cooperation at scale and you have
culture that comes along for the ride
and you have norms and you have emotions
but it like is there a First principles
this is moral this is not moral solution
yeah so we've been talking I think
largely about the science and morality
and now we're getting to more clearly
into moral philosophy
um so I think that's the first first
natural place to go when you're thinking
is there an objective morality can you
give me an objective moral code that
gives me the fundamental principles that
justifies everything else and the thing
is philosophers have been working on
that for thousands of years and they've
got approximately nowhere we have gotten
very little agreement about what the
fundamental moral principles are but I
do think that there has been
serious agreement about some moral
issues not fundamental principles but
certain kinds of
social changes in our society
that everyone or everyone that we want
to have as part of the conversation
thinks of that is Progressive
things like the elimination of chattel
slavery
greater equality between men and women
um reduced
Prejudice towards ethnic minorities
towards gay and lesbian people there are
progressive changes that I think we
should be far more con we should be far
more confident that these changes are
progressive than we are in any abstract
theory that explains why these things
are right or wrong and so I think the
best hope for finding some kind of
objective morality objective in the
sense that
we think that it's not it's not we're
not we don't just agree but we think
other people were wrong and that we are
getting we are coming to this view from
more information about ourselves and
what the world is like
I think the
the the their best hopes for an
objective moral philosophy
is to think about how and why these
Progressive changes happened the kinds
that I mentioned and to think about the
psychological and cultural mechanisms
behind them and whether those mechanisms
can be exploited in the future to bring
about future Progressive changes things
like addressing massive social
inequality thinking about anti-trans
Prejudice
um thinking about global Injustice the
way in which people from developing
countries are going to suffer from
climate change and other kinds of
disasters
I think that we're not going to figure
out whether utilitarianism is true or
not but we might be able to figure out
how we've made progress in ways that we
all agree in our progress and how to
build on those and to find agreement
about other pressing problems that we
haven't solved yet what could you
imagine as overshooting when it comes to
that particular type of dynamic
that's interesting overshooting so
you know addressing some of these
outstanding problems but
going too far in One Direction is that
what you have in mind yeah
yeah that's that's interesting I mean
I think that they're you know one of the
one of the things we see in human
history is expansion of the moral Circle
coming to care about more than just your
tribe
and not just your religiously unified
but uh Uber tribe
um I think that it is possible to go too
far into this Cosmopolitan Direction and
to think that
other people that strangers matter just
as much as your loved ones and your
friends do
I think that this is probably a tendency
on the left to minimize the importance
of intimate connections between friends
and family and to overestimate the
degree to wish
you have an obligation to strangers that
aren't part of your family or your your
tribe
that's interesting yes and I do I do
understand the the dynamic that you're
talking about where
uh the sort of deep pedestalization of
motherhood the Deep pedestalization of
the family illness being seen as some
sort of
um privileged or oppressive institution
you know we've seen this in like those
once every couple of months insane news
article titles that come up about like
the family is a a patriarchal
institution I saw one a little while ago
uh the myth of motherhood is uh is a
myth that men created in order to keep
women down and stuff like that and you
think well
I I it would have been very very
difficult for motherhood and and for
humans to have survived without
motherhood having been there and it is a
the subtext behind that is motherhood is
a myth you should care about everybody
the same amount that you should that you
would care about your children
yeah I mean I think that there are
aspects of family institutions that are
worth preserving the bonds that people
have towards family members the
important relationships between children
and caregivers that can't be replicated
can be outsourced to our institutions so
I think those parts of family
institutions are preserving I guess I
also think that there are aspects of
our historically evolved family
institutions that are oppressive towards
women that force them to occupy
subordinate social roles within the
family and to assign low status to
Motherhood
um
one of the fascinating things that I've
noticed is
um I I don't disagree that you know for
a good chunk of time there wasn't parity
in education employment Freedom autonomy
voting rights you know bank accounts
ability to drive remember reading this
article about
uh the concerns in the early 1900s that
the bicycle would emancipate women to be
able to go out on their own without the
supervision of their husbands because
typically women would only be able to go
out like linking up presumably linking
arms with their with their partner or
whatever
um so I do get that however
um what you have seen and that was what
that article showed is that if you push
the progressivism too far you end up
um how would you say like demonizing
some of the inherent Beauty and wisdom
that the feminine brings into the world
right in order for you to say that
motherhood the maternal instinct is a
myth that men created it inevitably puts
women
who are mothers back into that
second-class citizen role that they only
just got emancipated from you know what
I mean right yeah absolutely I mean I
think the a kind of feminism worth
having is one that expands up options
and possibilities for women and that
doesn't
um say that only the new possibilities
are worth having and um traditional
roles as mothers and caretakers aren't I
mean I think that what's really the key
the key part of the feminist movement
that
that I think many people should agree is
worth
preserving and continuing is
um expanding Liberty expanding freedom
of people uh of of all genders to
um to occupy social roles and economic
roles that they are interested in doing
you know I think that uh new options
doesn't mean we should devalue the old
ones yeah I would agree look Vic I
really appreciate your time today uh why
should people go if they want to keep up
to date with the work that you do
uh well they can read my new book called
better ape with Richmond Campbell they
can also check out my website for links
to new articles that I've written I have
an essay in the Boston Globe for
instance which you might like to read
very cool thanks Victor all right thank
you so much it was great to talk to you
Chris what's happening people thank you
very much for tuning in if you enjoyed
that episode then press here for a
selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
peace
foreign
[Music]